also I want to talk about before Tom
Rhodes gets here that's where our guest
is and I love him
did you see the Star Wars trailer I did
did you see it now I haven't how do you
feel about it I was excited ahh
I was excited are you one to think that
the last Jedi was one of the worst
movies ever made I did not like it
I don't think one of the worst Duty
admit this though it's the worst Star
Wars movie ever made
nope Episode two God you I have to be
honest the first three we charge are
being okay I'd rather do a charter a
punk
Ping's one-man show right underwater
with all this [ __ ] on I think you're
you're a little bit you get swayed a lot
by by public opinion because when you
walked out of there we watched it
together you were let go that was pretty
good I liked it then you watch all of
the reviewers you know I watch all the
reviewers then you started to really get
on their bandwagon it's true I'm sorry I
have to tell the world how you are what
you think about this one oh I just want
to say this okay that maybe you are
right maybe that there was okay I
remember watching the last Jedi and
walking out and you know what it is it's
like this it's it's it's so hyped and
because you the music you're so familiar
with the sound of the lightsaber you're
so familiar with you know the whole vibe
of it yeah it there's there's sprinkles
of nostalgia just by playing the music
and having certain characters in there
like Luke Skywalker right so you
subconsciously or whatever you just
convince yourself that this is a good
movie it's one of those movies where you
have to sit down and close your eyes and
think about and then you realize oh
nothing makes make sense and also I
didn't think that that Princess Leia in
the space thing frozen the Superman
thing was a ridiculous thing was that I
didn't think that that was great I
thought that wasn't what the [ __ ] is
this
was weird and then with them go to the
casino thing with Benicio del Toro it's
like oh it nothing happened right
and then the switcheroo with was a
lady with the purple hair give me the
feminists you know yet drazi Park I
thought last Jedi was women were Star
Wars movie but I had to give Disney and
Kathleen Kennedy some props by um
getting ryan johnson outta there and and
telling JJ abrams you have to direct
this to finish it off you have to do it
because it you still feel now you know
like okay we're kinda in good hands
maybe you know and they're gonna do
everything they can to make it up to the
fans that's all George Lucas is
supervising on some of it that's not
good news that was not good news what
you decided yeah I don't know man yeah
you know um I just I would really it's
but that franchise to me I think is kind
of dead in the because of the fact that
especially as an adult mm-hmm
you want somebody to make it that's a
little bit more edgy and dark right you
want them for me you know because Empire
Strikes Back was a dark movie he gets
his hand chopped off he finds out the
most evil person in the universe is his
dad mm-hm right he fall I remember the
whole scene where he's in the cloud city
is upside down with his hand off and
these dooms dooms it that his best
friend is frozen into a block of ice or
whatever that thing was and shipped the
job of the hut that that movie [ __ ] up
now and now and I was a kid watching it
so scared and so sad and devastated by
it but it also made me walk out of there
going that was [ __ ] cool and I could
handle it as a kid and now this foofy
[ __ ] that they're doing Disney
probably our children are far more
stronger than you think
look at the children like on Instagram
there with her Gucci Gucci and all that
what's the hoochie-coochie you know big
kids they go to you know I'm in
that's what I'm saying I've just heard
about it I just heard about the coochie
coochie-coo you know also the house is
coming up what easier
he'll be here right at 9:00 that's what
he said yeah okay um let's stop to stop
it and then that's pretty good well I've
got a great way to solve the the Star
Wars franchise what well you know how
the worst first one had like got
structure from Akira Kurosawa's the
hidden fortress
yes telling it from the perspective of
the Android standpoint important
characters yeah just rip off every
Kurosawa plot you know get han Solo in a
Yojimbo type of plot get a rash Mun plot
every plot has been the same for a long
time so why not just get some some good
plots in there that is I mean the I know
the Yojimbo plot though it's been tense
to me so many times in westerns yeah
that you know you can't do it you can't
incorporate but you can incorporate I
would like to see a Seven Samurai maybe
one where it's like um getting a ragtag
group of people to fight yeah you know I
mean the new Empire
maybe I have a question for you are you
the person who did this to my t-shirt I
haven't I don't know who did this I'm
gonna go grab Tom guys why would I do
that I didn't do that why would I do
that why would I do this because that's
not what work how people do they did the
yoga I stuck my body yeah I don't know
you guys just stretches on your right
side and you just want to show off this
mark
[Music]